over the weekend the big news was that
the meeting was going to happen Donald
Trump was going to be meeting with Kim
jong-un the North Korean leader to
negotiate at least as far as Donald
Trump wanted us to believe North Korea's
nuclear disarmament and the trumpets
were just on fire you should have seen
them all over my Twitter account all
over the weekend saying look at what
Donald Trump has been able to accomplish
this man is a genius he is a master deal
maker and negotiator you all said he'd
get nothing done here and he's made more
progress with North Korea getting Kim
jong-un to be willing to meet with him
it is incredible wow wow wow and then of
course we had to inject some connection
to the real world in this entire thing
and indeed we're now learning that it
all appears to have stemmed I don't even
know if I can call it a misunderstanding
but sort of stemmed from Trump's
incompetence and lack of knowledge of
how anything works with North Korea now
that those are pretty big claims I'm
making I should have to defend them and
I will this all started when a South
Korean official named Chun Hyang was at
the White House and according to the New
York Times Trump asked Chung to tell him
about his meeting with Kim jong-un and
Chung told Trump truthfully as far as we
know that Kim jong-un is interested in
meeting with Donald Trump Trump
immediately says yes I will do it and
then the headlines just explode too
something along the lines of Trump to
meet with kim jeong-hoon now the way it
was being reported and understood by
lots of people was that the breaking
news was that Kim jong-un was willing to
meet with Trump a fall along you believe
that Kim jong-un was not willing to meet
with Trump or former American presidents
when you hear a headline that says hey
things have changed Kim jong-un is now
willing to meet with Trump you think wow
that is major progress we've gone from
North Korean leadership being unwilling
to meet with American presidents - all
of a sudden
as president of the United States he
talks about a little Rokit man he talks
about a bloody nose strike and next
thing you know everything changes and
Kim jong-un wants to meet with Donald
Trump but that's what the trumpets and
Trump himself seemed to be missing over
the entire weekend which is that North
Korea under Kim jong-un under Kim
jong-il they've always wanted to meet in
person with an American president it's
the u.s. who has chosen not to do it
unless there were some preconditions
imposed concessions agreed to by the
North Korean side it's not newsworthy at
all that Kim jong-un wants to meet with
Donald Trump
the newsworthy part would be the
American policy change of Trump meeting
with Kim jong-un with no preconditions
and so immediately the White House
started walking all of this back and our
favorite press secretary Sarah Huckabee
Sanders told reporters a couple days ago
that actually no Trump is not just going
to show up and meet with Kim jong-un
there need to be concrete concessions
made beforehand and you'll notice this
is a basically completely opposed
situation a different situation than
what the headlines were claiming this
will be any more than a photo-op Kim
jong-un gets his equal footing in his
view on the world stage with a leader in
the free world I definitely don't think
that the president's getting nothing
when we've already said and frankly I've
said it many times since walking in here
in the last 10 minutes that the
president will not have the meeting
without seeing concrete steps and
concrete actions take place by North
Korea so the president would actually be
getting something and frankly the world
would be getting something if we can get
to a place where North Korea is
denuclearizing it is a massive step and
it's something that will make the entire
globe much safer and even president moon
has said that this is because of the
leadership of President Trump that's
right so after all the headlines and all
the tweets from the the trumpets about
Trump the hero the real situation is
that the American president is willing
to consider meeting with Kim jong-un
only with preconditions and
concessions which is exactly the old
policy nothing has changed that has been
the situation for a very long time in
the United States before Trump North
Korean leaders wanted to meet with
American presidents and American
presidents were only willing to consider
that if North Korea made concessions
before the meeting which they've not
been willing to do and now during Trump
it's the exact same same scenario so
Trump shot his mouth off because he
believed that it was notable that Kim
jong-un wanted to meet with him when it
was not that's really the funniest part
of all of this when the headlines broke
the trumpets thought that this was major
and also some of them thought that this
meant Kim jong-un was ready to disarm
that wanting a meeting with Trump met
Kim jong-un was ready to meet and say
I'm giving up my nukes Kim jong-un has
no interest in giving up his nukes he
wants to meet with president Trump to
convey power that he got a meeting with
Trump and he'll know that if he gets the
meeting it would be because he has the
nukes and people are afraid of how we
might use them the last thing that Kim
jong-un is going to do is meet with
Trump to get rid of the nukes and you've
got to put yourself in his shoes right
if you're in the situation of Kim
jong-un in North Korea Kim jong-un knows
that the nukes are hugely important as a
bargaining chip and this also applies to
newer reports from the last few hours
that Kim jong-un wants a peace treaty
with the United States this by some on
the trumpets right is being reported as
look at what Kim jong-un is willing to
do for Trump Kim jong-un has always
wanted others to do for them things and
that's what this is it's not take my
nukes and nothing bad will happen it's
we want the u.s. to agree to X Y Z more
than likely that would include a formal
end to the Korean War which from the
point of view of Kim jong-un would
necessitate the total removal of all US
forces from South Korea which is not
going to happen so listen I'm not saying
this is a bad idea I would love for the
United States to reduce its military
footprint around the world I would love
for there to be action
will productive disarmament talks with
North Korea but the fantasy that Trump
achieved something big and that Kim
jong-un is just willing to give
everything up now because of the power
of Donald Trump it is an absolute and
total fantasy yeah I'm a little
disappointed because it doesn't seem
like this meeting is going to happen
after all no and I think only good can
come from this meeting right you have
two people sitting at a table together
we know that Trump is good schmoozer and
he can wine and dine Kim jong-un and
maybe they'll both come out of it
feeling better are you
is that tongue-in-cheek or is that for
real no I really think that I remember
Obama during the campaign in 2008 yeah
about how he would meet with Iran
without precondition yep is it so bad if
Trump does it with kim jong hoon i think
the difference is if you get to
megalomaniacs
who do have access to nuclear weapons
together in a room with each other when
one of those megalomaniacs also knows
nothing about anything I think it's a
recipe for disaster I think the way that
this need if you're gonna do this
seriously right if you're gonna do this
seriously what you have to do is say
great we're going to have a North Korean
US summit probably with South Korean
officials as well and maybe even other
allies and they are going to really do
the bulk of the actual negotiation
without the megalomaniacs in the room
and then once we come to what will be in
principle and agreement we will have
something more ceremonial for Trump and
Kim jong-un to get together and maybe
shake hands or whatever and I want to be
clear I would want that to happen I've
been pointing to the North Korean
situation as one that we would all
benefit from having a resolution to but
we've got to be realistic and the idea
that you're gonna put two megalomaniacs
in the room and everything's just gonna
work out great
I think it's laughable but it's also
laughable that Trump and the trumpets
fell hook line and sinker for something
that's not news Kim jong-un has been
thrilled for years about the possibility
of being seen as a serious enough player
geopolitically to meet with an American
president and it's been the United
States who has said hold on a second if
we're gonna do that then we're gonna
need some concessions and yet this is
the latest episode by the way
in Sarah Huckabee Sanders regular series
of look the president clearly meant X
even though the president said why that
that should be like the epitaph on her
burial headstone look the president
clearly meant because all she does is
tell us what it actually means when
Trump says we're gonna meet with kim
jeong-hoon yeah she's still my second
favorite White House press secretary I
like Sean Spicer even more yeah I I find
Spicer less vile
I guess is what I would say but I don't
know that I really am I don't believe
either of them is contributing to the
forward progress of democracy in sort of
any major way the video you just
finished watching was made possible by
you through the membership program you
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership